son económico de Bolivia bloqueado los
sectores afines al gobierno de Luis Arce
han puesto en marcha un cierre de las
carreteras que llevan a la ciudad
prohibiendo la llegada de alimentos a la
región estuvo en respuesta a la huelga
iniciada por opositores mientras el
gobierno prohíbe la exportación desde
Santa Cruz de varios productos como el
azúcar la carne o la soya para evitar la
escasez no estamos de acuerdo con ningún
Zarco a ningún lado el cerco discriminar
el cerco ya nos ha dado la experiencia
de que lo único que hace es enfrentarnos
entre bolivianos los manifestantes
exigen un censo previsto para 2022 pero
que el gobierno de Luis Arce decidió
aplazar a 2024 por problemas técnicos
según los opositores de Santa Cruz la
ciudad ha recibido mucha migración en
los últimos años y un nuevo censo Podría
tener influencia en la distribución
presupuestal al igual que en la
atribución escaños parlamentarios de
Cara a las elecciones de 2025 lo que hay
que especificar claramente es que el
gobierno tenía la obligación de realizar
el censo este año 2022 y lo está
pateando porque no le conviene porque
necesito un padrón inflado porque no
quiere redistribuir recursos no nos
quiere dar escaños el gobierno vamos a
estar robando los cochabambinos nos
están robando dos escaños no están
robando plata Entonces eso es lo que no
se puede permitir el gobierno ha
convocado un diálogo para este viernes
en la ciudad de Cochabamba pero los
líderes de la manifestación no se han
mostrado abiertos a participar el
movimiento se extendió a otras ciudades
del país y se registraron
enfrentamientos en la paz y en tarija